I don't know anyone who could have
handled what you I'm so proud of you
every single day for the way that you
live your life I wish that everybody
knew how beautiful and delicious your
heart was thank you and they would never
live in a guilt thinking like I wish I
didn't you know help all my kids get
famous you just can't live like that
this is also our Journeys and we wanted
this and you just helped us fulfill our
dreams and like what our potential was
yeah you know life is about hardships
and how you get through them yeah and we
know how to get through them yeah we do
the one thing we do I think like the
Kardashians like we don't stoop to
anyone's level and we get through things
and we get through them together thank
God we have each other thank God we have
that support system that is what I base
a lot of My Sanity on it's our Saving
Grace that we get to learn sanity one
another yeah that's a gift I hope you
appreciate that gift no I do